on your
[Silence]
similar.
But now you're going to
[Silence]
imagine
no
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
The
Yesterday we began began discussing the
second invalidator of Udul or we should
say we
you know differentiated
between a couple of important principles
with respect to the second invalidator
of wudoo which is deep sleep. We said
deep sleep is an invalidator of wudoo
irrespective of a person's posture
during this deep sleep. Irrespective of
the position that the person is in. If
it is deep sleep
a person's woo is no longer
a certainty.
Therefore, a person must make his woo
over.
I'll give you an example of deep sleep.
You ever see someone sit during awa
and start to snore?
They're sitting right next to the
speaker
and they are sleeping so nicely and so
comfy.
that the is called
and everyone stands up for salah and
they still need to be woken up so that
they can stand up and make salah. Have
you ever seen that before? I hope that
you're not that guy.
This person has wudoo or does not have
wudoo.
What's the answer? He does not have woo.
Why?
Because this is deep sleep.
What's the difference between deep and
light sleep?
[Arabic recitation]
environment. Yes. Awareness.
Because if a person is not aware of his
surroundings, he's not aware of what his
body is doing. The whole idea behind
light sleep not being an invalidator of
wudoo is that if a person were to break
his wudoo while in this light sleep he
would know it.
However, if a person is sleeping
so deeply that they do not hear the they
do not hear hundreds of feet standing
and stamping on the ground. This person
needs to make his woo.
Now, here's the question. Have you ever
seen that guy? We've all seen that guy,
right? Have you ever seen that guy go
make wool before coming back to pray?
No, you haven't. Unfortunately, is that
prayer valid or invalid?
Invalid.
Imagine taking the time out of your day,
driving,
parking,
doing all that just to do what? just to
go home with nothing to ruin it for
something silly. And you see people do
this constantly.
The prophet sallallah.aii was tells us
and so whoever
plays or fidgets with the with
something then this person has broken
his silence.
This person has broken his legislative
silence which invalidates the reward of
Jym. And you see people do it all the
time and it's so sad because this person
clearly has some
desire for the reward of Allah
and unfortunately they may go a year or
two or 10 or 20 or 30
and because of a text message here or
let me just check my email real quick or
let me just message this person
something real quick
because of the advent event of the cell
phone. It is hard to find someone that
will make it through J without
invalidating the reward of his J.
And this is what is sad about it because
what could be worse than meeting Allah
thinking that you have something in the
bank and there is nothing there?
What could be worse than standing in
front of Allah
and only to find out that the reward for
your prayer has been invalidated because
the row is unstraight and sloppy because
it was too much effort to make sure that
the row and your place in the row is
straight. If you stand out of place in
the row, what happens to the reward of
the prayer?
Everyone suffers because of that.
Whenever people get together to do
something collectively, what one person
does affects the entire group. And it's
that for a reason. So that no one
can come and say, well, you know,
right?
I'm doing my people don't do what they
don't do. That's their business. There's
no such thing as that's their business.
The Muslim, the believer is the mirror
image of his brother. If he sees
something wrong, he fixes it. He fixes
it in the best of ways, right?
And
now with the advent of cell phones, we
see that much of our prayer has been
destroyed, much of our focus has been
destroyed. And with the advent of the
internet, we have the emergence of what?
The pseudo scholar. What is the pseudo
scholar?
Well, if you tell them anything, you
say, but this is a difference of opinion
amongst the scholars. You can't say
anything to anyone anymore.
Say the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said this. They reply with what? Yeah,
but this is a difference of opinion.
What does that mean? We are repeating
statements that we don't even know the
meaning of. This does not take away from
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
from the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's
statements and
and not only that but unfortunately with
the advent of the internet and we as a
minority living amongst the majority of
non-Muslims
our language starts to change and when
our language changes our beliefs change
with them
what for instance
what do we call it when a person
is presented with the truth but their
instinct is to protect themselves
and
reject this truth. We say this person
is rejecting this out of what?
We have a very specific word.
No English
starts with an ego.
Ego. What is ego?
Ego. Ego.
This is the ego speaking.
There is no ego in the Quran. There's no
ego in the sunnah. What do we call it in
the Quran and Sunnah?
That's the act. But what is the ego in
If we don't even know how to properly
diagnose the problem, how are we going
to correct it? Ego comes from Freudian
psychiatry, psychology,
right? You can have your choice. Freud
who thinks that everything
everything every decision a person
makes, everything a person does is all
driven purely by sexual desire and the
urge to reproduce. Even the connection
between a brother and sister. Even the
connection between a brother and his
brother is driven entirely by what?
Bisexual
by by what is called libido,
right?
Or you can have the yungian
ideology of ego where ego is in the
front and then the shadow self is in the
back and the shadow self is the
repressed self.
If you repress all those bad urges, one
day they're going to come back out and
then you're going to turn into a
narcissist, etc. All these words that we
have no place in the Quran and Sunnah
for them. Our language is being
replaced.
The point here is that back to our
person sleeping during Juma, this person
needs to be told by everyone what? Go
make wudoo. You don't have udoo. No, I
was sleeping sitting up. You didn't know
what was going on. A freight train could
have driven right through here and you
would not have been the wiser. You have
to make wudoo because sleep breaks woo
according to the consensus of all of the
the consensus of all of the
awareness.
Whether a person is sitting up
completely resting all of his weight
on his behind or not. This breaks a
person's woo irrespective of a person's
posture.
[Silence]
hadith
So we see here that in this narration of
and this narration is mentioned
in the first chapter of
as well. We see here that
tells us three things that break a
person's woo. He says
defecating and urinating and sleep.
So defecating and urinating and sleep.
So he made these three whats equal.
They're the same thing. Person uses the
restroom or sleeps deeply. This is
considered what? an invalidator of
[Silence]
We can't
We
[Silence]
can't do
We will continue this tomorrow in
[Silence]
Allah. Subhan Allah. for
[Arabic recitation]